let's bring in Melvin Gordon the
Chargers running back joining us on the
show
Melvin good morning where are you today
okay okay all right so you're in the
training room right now I'm assuming
you're playing Saturday night yeah okay
so you're playing Saturday night yeah
okay thanks what's the best Christmas
gift you ever got you don't celebrate it
really you got no gifts I'm kind of
bummed out you know that you didn't get
any Christmas guests Melvin you can't
miss all right we did have a contest
here we want to know the over-under is
three and a half names of Phillip Rivers
kids how many can you name okay wait let
me let's go around the room first and
who thinks Melvin can name more he can
name four of Phillip Rivers kids Phil of
14 yes
you say yes seat and says yeah over
McLovin you're going under three and a
half yep okay Paulie under Melvin's
folks on the playbook
okay um I'm good at I'm gonna go under
I'm gonna say Melvin can name three of
Phillip Rivers kids
Melvin how many can you name one he's
gonna grace you're just throwing a name
out Gunnar's one for sir Gunnar and
grace and then it might be a Sarah so go
six but that's three doe he's got he's
got his ninth kid on the way Melvin
yeah you do man that's pretty good yeah
I mean they yeah yes eat and what do you
have let's say I've got seven names here
there's gunner oh and Pete and Pete
Gracie said he said gracious to Pete all
the time so I'm Peters one and son yeah
Peters and Harvey yep yep there's Peter
there's a Sarah Hallie
all right he got he got out he got the
over Caroline Rebecca Greyson gunner
well done well done with that yeah
what's the difference in the running
back position now as opposed to when you
came into the league in 2015 we're doing
a lot more you know I feel like we've
been passing the ball in the league when
I can't lose passes a lot I feel like
we're you know we're showing a little
more like sort of running back I feel
like when I first got here he was kind
of getting overlooked a lot not kind I
feel like his word and I feel like this
this time you know since I've been in I
said a lot of back they've been doing
their thing to kind of put us on the map
best running back in football is who me
second best running back in football is
cream heart
well he's not not there anymore what
about Todd Gurley but how much how much
competition is there with running backs
it feels like all the quarterbacks get
along with each other do is there a
fraternity of running backs like do you
guys support each other or are you guys
in competition no we definitely support
each other when I got hurt when Jay got
hurt my car Jay says I I think he's the
top dog back in this league to tie that
call Jay when I got hurt Todd I called
me so it's not like you know we you know
we
look up one another man it's not like we
I mean obviously we we all compete
against each other but we're we're
Brotherhood man and we've been knowing
each other for real you know since since
we got our since he's been in college
you know me and Todd and we always had a
big group we got a big group message I
was like a big thing coming out and we
always talked me him Duke Johnson Mike
Davis so we all like man we Brotherhood
for a man we look up Lonnie knows him
but he definitely called me man no
that's cool it's a Melvin Gordon the
Chargers running back they've got the
Ravens coming up on Saturday night do
you mind if people are jumping on the
Chargers bandwagon now that you're 11
and 3 yeah we just need to have more
people show up for the games here Melvin
that'll be good we get that we don't be
alright have you gone to a Laker game
since LeBron came to town you go to the
Clippers game well you could you should
go to a go out there yeah why don't you
leave tickets from LeBron to go to a
Chargers game I would like everybody
just on the Rams bandwagon you got oh I
went because my best friend's place for
Minnesota so I went to that game verse
you know Minnesota and around Floyd
Mayweather
[Laughter]
you got a win and if you win then
they're gonna show up the stars will
show up if you guys go to the Superbowl
not that the Rams have done anything
recently but you know they got their
first and it feels like you know they
locked in on fans coming out they were
successful early I think that's what you
got to do you win you win a Super Bowl
then all of a sudden the Brauns gonna
hit you up and say hey I'm thinking
about bringing my kids out to watch
charger again hey man look last time I
checked the Rams they want a super boy
okay
would you love to play the riff you
could play anybody in the NFC you could
pick who do you want the Rams
it'd be one with LA yeah then you could
settle it you could settle the battle
for LA yeah for sure I think that would
be that would be if that would happen L
AM asked for a regardless so they don't
even care who it is
they just yeah they just ready for the
party but would you if you scored a
touchdown would you give a football to
Floyd Mayweather or would you keep it
yeah but he's a Rams guy he went to a
Rams game thank you yeah but that's how
you get guys that's how you guys come on
three games do you have any celebrity
who's the biggest celebrity shows up for
the charge again though we got Kobe what
did he do when he came to practice he
gave speech oh yeah so I mean we got
that going for us
all right you think all right no I mean
it's good it's a start here Melvin I
mean I look I got you guys going to the
Super Bowl so I'm on the bandwagon
already you'll have to convince me I
don't need celebrities I don't need
speeches I just need good football
that's it
you know maybe let's let's kind of shut
down Lamar Jackson on Saturday night
about that yep got to do that but you
know what maybe I get how about I get
Will Ferrell to come out to again that
would be amazing
let's see what I can do I mean I the
only so much I can do but they're my
Chargers and if this will help morale be
more than happy to do it
what kind of football player do you
think nobody would have made oh yeah
the only way that all the fame baby
maybe any big to you know saying you got
a a he ain't letting up Kobe he probably
a Hall of Fame for his mindset would he
be like Tina and Ellen oh I guess you
could say that he played basketball yeah
he'd be like a keen an outlet he big so
you think oh can't be able to catch
right yeah he's got great hands you
would think oh we do but all right who
would be a better football player LeBron
or Kobe ooh I say LeBron because he's a
he's a bigger body put him at tight end
you put him a receiver and he'd be like
Megatron
oh you think you'd be like Calvin
Johnson like that yeah yeah I think I
think I don't do that little you see him
play flag football Kevin grant I kind of
like what I was watching
yeah I have fun tomorrow night and the
postseason as well and congrats on the
season so far Millman Thank You Man I
appreciate it I appreciate you you know
rock a little Sarge's man I appreciate
that
well the great ones knew that you guys
were gonna be great this year so Thank
You Melvin that's Melvin Gordon charges
running back I didn't know about the
Christmas thing I mean I feel bad but if
he didn't celebrate it or you know see I
think he grew up Jehovah's Witness is
that what it was
they don't sell okay okay all right I
wasn't sure if it was religious related
but yeah
no big deal but yeah I was he didn't
know what he was missing because he
didn't he didn't celebrate it because
they didn't know what he's missing yeah
yeah are you sure yeah yeah I didn't we
didn't celebrate Christmas we don't
complain black should we do all the time
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]